y en donde nos quedamos me acuerdo que
teníamos que llegar a este castillo como
fuera porque teníamos que salvar a
alguien pero el problema es que teníamos
que cruzar a este río y para cruzar este
río tenemos que pasar por el puente y en
el puente había un gnomo y el gnomo nos
había cobrado cinco pesos por cruzar el
puente sin embargo no teníamos de dinero
y por lo tanto nos dio una oportunidad
de resolver un acertijo para cruzar el
puente y para esto nos dio estas dos
pistas las cuales estoy representando de
esta manera matemáticamente hablando si
no contestamos correctamente a este
acertijo entonces el gnomo nos va a
aumentar el río y entonces estamos bajo
presión y bueno lo que quiero ver en
este vídeo es que estas dos ecuaciones
matemáticas que tengo aquí las podemos
resolver de varias formas pero en este
primer vídeo quiero intentar resolverlas
de una manera visual así que déjame
dibujar dos ejes por aquí y en el primer
eje lo voy a llamar el eje de las f
mientras que el segundo eje lo voy a
llamar el eje de las text y vamos a
poner nuestra escala voy a decir que
aquí son 500 monedas de 10 y aquí son
1000 monedas de 10
y lo mismo para t no perdón 500 más de 5
y mil monedas de 5 lo mismo para temer
aquí voy a suponer que son 500 monedas
de 10 y aquí voy a suponer que son mil
monedas de 10 y lo primero que voy a
hacer es fijarme en esta línea que voy a
dibujar en amarillo que dice que este es
igual a 900 esto quiere decir que a lo
más podemos tener 900 monedas de 5 y en
este caso tendríamos 0 monedas de 10 que
es justo este punto que tengo aquí es el
punto cero 900 0,900 en el caso de que
tenemos 900 monedas de 5 o en el otro
caso es que tenemos 900 monedas de 10
este pues es nuestro otro caso extremo
en el cual tenemos 900 nuevas de 10 y 0
monedas de 5 y bueno aquí viene lo
importante todas las posibles
combinaciones que existen de monedas de
5 y de monedas de 10 que me den 900 son
todas estas que están dibujadas aquí en
esta línea recta cualquier combinación
de cantidad de monedas de 10 y de
cantidad de monedas de 5 que nos den 900
900 monedas tienen que estar sobre esta
línea y por suerte también el gnomo nos
dio un según
una segunda pista que es esta que
tenemos aquí la cual dice que 5 f este
es igual a 5500 así que para representar
la de una manera gráfica voy a hacer
exactamente lo mismo voy a ver qué es lo
que pasa cuando f vale 0 y cuando te
vale 0 y para hacer esas cuentas voy a
hacer una tabla aquí para ver qué es lo
que nos resulta voy a buscar los valores
de t y los valores de f y en el primer
caso voy a decir qué te vale 0 si te va
de 0 entonces esta parte se cancela y me
queda que es 5 efe es igual al 5500 y
dividiendo entre 5 me queda que f es
igual a 1100 ahora vamos a ver qué es lo
que pasa cuando f vale cero cuando f
vale cero pues esta parte se cancela y
me queda de éste y este igual a 5500
dividiendo entre 10 me queda que t es
igual a 550 y bueno ya con estos valores
de t y de f
vamos a graficar los si te vale 0 f vale
1100 estamos en este punto en el 0 mil
100 ya tenemos un punto y ahora me voy a
fijar en el siguiente punto que dice que
cuando f vale 0 te vale 550 así que voy
a suponer que que hay 600 700 800 900 y
1000 y por aquí está 550 voy a suponer
que es éste
y entonces estamos en el punto 550 como
0 y de igual manera voy a unir esos dos
puntos en una recta en una línea así que
por aquí está mi línea recta y bueno
déjenme hacerlo un poco mejor vamos a
hacer un segundo intento de dibujar esta
línea recta por aquí va mi línea recta
que representa a la segunda pista déjame
hacerlo por una tercera vez para que
quede perfectamente bien esta segunda
línea recta que es más o menos así ya
está mucho mejor la segunda pista la
segunda ecuación que tengo queda
representada por esta línea recta que
estoy pintando de azul y bueno aquí
viene lo más importante estoy buscando
un punto que cumpla que viva en ambas
líneas rectas simultáneamente es decir
que tanto esté en la primera línea recta
como una segunda línea recta o dicho de
otra manera que satisfaga las dos
ecuaciones simultáneamente y es justo en
ese momento que hemos de decir que es
este punto de aquí en el punto del que
se intersectan las dos líneas rectas
este punto existe tanto en la línea de
amarillo como en la línea de azul y por
lo tanto está tanto en mi primera
actuación como en mi segunda ecuación
que si más o menos le calculamos y de
hecho te encargó que hagas la gráfica
de una manera muy precisa para que te
des cuenta a bien qué punto es este pero
si más o menos lo calculamos nos vamos a
dar cuenta que f vale como 700 mientras
que te va a valer 200 así que déjame
ponerlo por aquí estamos en el valor de
700 en f es decir tenemos 700 monedas de
5 pesos mientras que por otro lado
tenemos 200 monedas de 10 pesos te vale
200 y aunque por aquí no se ve muy
preciso déjame ver si realmente si
cumple ambas ecuaciones 700 más 200 es
lo mismo que 900 y por otra parte cinco
veces cf es decir cinco por setecientos
lo cual de es 3505 por 703 mil
quinientos pesos más 10 veces tiene es
decir 10 por 210 por 200 porque te vale
200 en este punto lo cual son dos mil
pesos tiene que ser igual a 5500 pero
tres mil quinientos más dos mil es lo
mismo que cinco mil quinientos y
entonces también cumplimos la segunda
ecuación y por lo tanto cumplimos las
dos ecuaciones simultáneamente y ya con
todo el valor del mundo le decimos al
gnomo ya sé cuántas monedas tienes
tantos
como de cinco pesos tiene setecientas
monedas de cinco y por otra parte tiene
doscientas monedas de diez así que no me
queda sorprendido y te dejé cruzar el
puente para que tú puedas ser el héroe o
la heroína de esta aventura